salut et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
vidéo qui a peut-être on sait d'ailleurs
statistiquement sur la chaîne vous êtes
environ 300 milles à suivre ma chaîne
par les casse têtes environ 200 milles à
suivre sur les scripts à environ 400
milles à supplée matière grise en vrai
vous venez chercher ce que vous voulez
sur la chaîne parlement mais moi ça me
va bien il n'y a pas de problème
aujourd'hui on se fait là les bbox qui a
été créée par constantin on l'a chopé
celle un solide casse tête meilleures
boîtes de casse têtes en france
si je vous recommande sa 100% vraiment
les casse tête que j'utilise viennent de
là-bas donc n'hésitez pas je vous remets
un lien dans la description c'est parti
pour sa loïc est ce que tu penses que je
vais le réussir ce sont ces salles been
eric était de chez constantin aussi
d'ailleurs
parce qu'il n'ya pas
un tac tac tac tac bon on est partis
là-dessus il vaut environ 80 euros il en
difficulté 6 sur 6 donc c'est quoi c'est
sûr que c'est pas bon signe
et juste avant que la vidéo commence
sachez que je reprends les dates de
spectacles à tourner enfin elle reprend
pour terminer ce spectacle que j'aurais
dû terminer début 2020 donc là vous
voyez toutes les villes où je vais
passer en france en belgique et en
suisse
si vous voyez pas votre ville c'est
normal c'est que je suis déjà passé deux
ou trois fois donc je termine à tourner
là où je ne suis pas encore passé
n'hésitez pas à réserver vos places
y compris pour le scénic de paris le 11
décembre le compte sur vous pour du
mentalisme du rire et des légumes
ouais bon pour la santé c'est parti les
bbox tout mettre mes petites lunettes
quand même alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
constater effectivement il ya un
labyrinthe
bon il n'y a pas besoin de faire
d'exploration ce qu'on a à faire est
très très clairs dessus c'est à dire il
va falloir ouvrir ça pour ouvrir ça il
va falloir utiliser les l'algarve ya
deux types de l'homme qui implique un
labyrinthe où tout est connecté ensemble
l'ugtg et là il ya un labyrinthe où
c'est que des carrés qui sont pas
connectés les uns aux autres par contre
et les tiges en métal sont associés deux
partent eux donc il va falloir trouver
le système pour enlever seule question
quand même que je me pose c'est lui ok
j'imagine que c'est possible de le tirer
entièrement puisque tout est connecté
qui a une sortie mais lui pas du tout du
coup puisqu'ils sont pas connectés les
uns aux autres pour les parties je me
dis là j'aimerais que lui ça parle donc
je le lève il faudrait que je puisse
tirer ça mais pour tirer ça lui il
faudrait qu'il soit plus en haut mais
pour que lui soit en haut il va falloir
que je bous lui colle à la haye et on a
compris ou pas ça va être exponentielle
pour bouger le be il faudra que je sois
comme ça ça me permet de mettre lui
parce que j'ai déjà dit ce que je
voulais faire mais oui je veux cuit
alliance donc pour que lui à lyon où il
faut que lui aussi la ion là si je fais
ça je peux encore faire ça donc là il
peut aller au hockey ça c'est bon
maintenant lui j'ai besoin qu'il aille
tout temps aussi des chansons à temps
pourquoi je veux qu'il aille en avril
pour tirer vers la abel ont donc lui
j'ai pas besoin qu'il aille au parce
qu'il peut là
attirés vers la lui il peut pas il
faudrait que lui par contre faudrait
qu'ils soient en hausse
donc cela si je fais ça c'est bon hockey
et lui à lui par contre j'ai besoin
qu'il soit ici là qu'ils soient tous là
où l'eau donc dans ce cas il faudrait
que je puisse faire comme ça ah la vache
à merde
ah ouais bah non là ils m'arrange pas
donc en fait j'aurais dû partir de lui
parce que oui je vais avoir besoin de le
pousser et la gelée mis en position où
je pourrai tirer
on reprend tout à zéro implique donc
pour tous et lui lui c'est bon c'est
repoussé lui faudra qu'il soit vraiment
complètement en bas une fois
complètement en bas il faudrait que je
fasse ça et ça c'est pour une là il est
complètement bas donc là je pourrai
poussé là je pourrai poussé l'âge
pourrait pousser lui maintenant j'ai
besoin que lui soit en bas du cou donc
je les déplacés pour rien donc hop hop
qu'il faudrait je leur montre la lâche
le bc lui j'ai dit il faut que je le
pousse et pour le plus c'est toi tu dois
être en bas et voilà j'ai pu le pousser
comme ça le 8 je vais pouvoir le monter
mais pour le monter annoncé les vrais
trucs de pétage de câble comme ça ok
donc là et lui il est positionné là haut
je veux donc ça c'est quand même plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
je voudrais que lui soient descendus et
là je peux pousser comme ça et là
pourquoi je peux plus parce que lui il
faudrait que je monte
pour monter il faut que je prouve lui
donc lui dow jones comme ça et demi
comme ça et du coup lui tout en haut et
plus pour le mettre tout en å il faut
que je fasse comme ça
et du coup lâche peu ok ok c'est pas
c'est pas si mal que pour le haut le bas
je comprends toujours pas comment on va
se débrouiller mais je romps verra dans
un second temps c'est pas très grave
là il faut que je continue à tirer du
coup c'est lui qui va falloir que
j'avance hockey et donc lui je vais
bientôt avoir libéré cette tige à ce qui
doit quand même fortement marange est là
maintenant il faudra qu'il redescende la
fois que je repousse c'est facile et là
que je fasse comme ça c'est bon là
pourquoi ça bloque à cause de lui lui
c'est bon et là ça peut être aussi grave
à cause de lui donc la up
ensuite à ela faut je repousse aweys est
liquidé les coudes et c'est la mort en
fait ok ok il a maintenant il faut que
je tire lui ou man n'empêche lui c'est
bon lui c'est bon hélas lui il va
falloir qu'ils redescendent complet pour
redescendre complet je passe par là et
lui du coup sa monnaie qui soit la
lentille tac tac tac tac
ok ok ok ok d'accord la wii si je fais
ça c'est bon et là je récupère encore la
coudée donc là c'est bon là ça c'est bon
ça c'est bon ça c'est bon ça c'est bon
comment je peux faire là pour lui il
faut que je tire donc là il faudrait
qu'ils lui je m comme çà comme çà comme
çà comme çà comme çà c'est pas sinon ça
sort pas trop mal là
qu'est ce qui m'empêche là il faut que
je fasse un retour tac tac tac tac tac
tac tac tac tac tac tac tac tac tac
[Musique]
levin présente ses fines
parce que cette manière on peut pas le
libérer puisqu'il est comme ça et donc
là je peux faire ça et ensuite je fais
sa boîte ouverte tant des joueurs
commencent à fait content moins d'une
minute pour faire ce cast et ses
incroyables ou pas ok alors j'essaie de
le faire dans l'autre sens un 6 sur 6
pourtant ou alors c'est que je commence
à être rodé à ce style la casse tête
hein c'est possible il est réglé à lège
essai de clerc dans l'autre sens parce
que on le sait et j'aimerais d'ailleurs
loïc que tu me l'as fitch toute forme de
citation un casse tête n'est vraiment
résolu que quand il a été remis dans son
état initial
[Musique]
et voilà un casse-tête en rondement
menée bon ben la ebox alors je les ferai
vie n'a pas se mentir je pensais
vraiment d'avoir pour mineurs j'en ai
pour sept minutes défaire et je pense à
peu près autant à le refaire mais très
satisfaisant à faire mais peut-être je
vais vite parce que ces genres de double
labyrinthe avec connexion et des
connexions d'un côté et c'est peut-être
que je commence à être rodé à ça en tout
cas je vous mettrais comme d'habitude à
gagner sur instagram sur cette photo là
merci beaucoup lake n'hésitez pas du
coup avis le contraste à il ya juste
marquer comment faire un boulet qu'est
la vidéo et qui la photo sur un stade et
puis c'est bon quand vous étiez ressort
alger et je ne mets pas 3000 truc ce que
ses roues prenez soin de vous suivez moi
sur un stade n'hésitez pas si vous
voulez la lecture qui vous permet de
comprendre le casse tête qu'est la tête
je vous conseille lentilles de la
manipulation principalement parce que
c'est moi qu'il l'écrit en gros c'est
comment reprendre le pouvoir sans abîmer
celui des autres vous avez le lien dans
la description pour en savoir plus
je compte sur vous pourrez jeter un
petit coup d'oeil quant à vous prenez
soin de vous mais moi je vous embrasse
la cassette vidéo si elle vous a plu je
m'appelle toujours fabien olicard ça ne
change jamais abonnez-vous évidemment à
cette chaîne à la chaîne secondaire et à
la chaîne de la maman de loïc qui va
lancer une chaîne de confiture
allô maman tu ouvres une chaîne de
confiture ça alors allô c'est une exclu
on vous mettra le lien bientôt dans la
description prenez soin foule à très
bientôt